suggested Department memo shows 65
doctors pharmacies and drug companies
receive suspension orders in the 2011
fiscal year before the new law this year
only six have gotten them and the DEA
has issued no suspension orders against
a distributor for nearly two years the
agency says in a statement it will
continue a quote to use all the tools at
our disposal to combat this epidemic
Paula Reid is in Washington with other
factors that interfere with enforcement
Paula good morning good morning the
Justice Department does not dispute any
60 minutes reporting it says the drug
crisis is a top priority for the Trump
administration but the DA's efforts may
have been undermined by the so-called
revolving door culture here in
Washington at least 46 investigators
attorneys and supervisors from the DEA
including 32 from the division that
regulate the drug industry have been
hired by the pharmaceutical industry
since scrutiny on distributors began
among them linden barber former
associate chief counsel at the DEA he's
now senior vice president at Cardinal
Health one of the nation's top drug
distributors Mike Gill chief of staff
for the former acting DEA administrator
was hired by one of the country's
largest healthcare firms and Jason
Hodges a senior DEA attorney overseeing
enforcement joined the pharmaceutical
division of a high-powered DC law firm
we reached out to former acting DEA
administrator Chuck Rosenberg who
oversaw the agency from May 2015 until
earlier this month when he stepped down
he says he has not seen the 60 minute
story and does not plan on watching it
Alex Paula thanks